(club music)
- It looks like a shitty building,
but on the inside it feels
like a fire-lit castle.
- Is everybody inside already?
- Yeah, Trey, the guy who
Shelby's roommate's dating,
he plays one of the wizards,
I don't wanna ruin anything for you
but they do magic.
- I.D.?
- Sure. That is weird,
I do not have my ID.
- Oh well, then step aside, man.
Sorry, I got other people.
- I mean I'm with her, my
friends are inside already.
Alright, I probably have it in here.
Hang on, hang on, hang on.
The DMV gave me this temporary license.
Here's a receipt to a
rental car I got in Oxnard,
you need to be 25 to get one of those.
- Just, see you in there?
- Okay I'll see you inside.
- [Britney] Okay.
- I can call my mom. Do
you want me to call my mom?
I'm an aquarius. I was
the year of the dragon.
I got three dollars on
me. Want three dollars?
- [Bouncer] Three dollars?
- Three Washingtons?
Mom, How old am I?
Yeah, its a Tuesday, it doesn't
this isn't about whether
it's a Tuesday or not.
Trey, Trey, is one of the wizards
I swear to God I know him.
- Yeah, there's a lot of wizards.
- Google this name and see if me comes up.
- Facebook will prove it for me.
I don't hate you, but I hate everything
you say in front of everything
you're saying right now.
Friend request yourself.
This is a legal document.
You think I just know this information?
You think I just made this information up?
Look man, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
for any trouble I caused.
I know you're just doing your job,
but I'm wondering if
maybe you could just ...
- I need ID!
- Hey, hey! You kinda look like me.
Here. Just pass your ID back.
Just, Oh, Yeah!
- No
- That could totally be
me, just pass it back.
(knocks on door)
Britney!
(kicks on door)
Hey, what was your favorite
Nickelodeon show in the 90s?
'Cuz I could name like 17 of them,
because I was a child during the 90s.
You want me to tell you about TRL?
I remember how the world felt after 9/11.
- Oh my God.
- Do you realize that people who
were born in 1995 could get in this bar?
Do you think they remember 9/11?
Do you think they remember.
Can I touch you right now?
- No, you cannot touch me.
- Alright, I'm gonna
go. I'm gonna come back.
Okay, this building just
doesn't have any windows.
Is that what's going on?
- Oh, fine. Alright, look, it's last call.
You can go in for the last half hour.
Just next time, bring your ID, okay?
- Oh my God, yes, thank you so much.
- No, no don't hug me.
- You won't regret this.
- Whatever.
- Woo! We're going to Fiddlesticks.
- No, no, wait.
- We're going to Fiddlesticks.
'Cuz the owner that I met
is gonna meet us there,
and then I grinded on him.
(dance club music)
- You're like Brink, you're a Brink guy.
You're a soul skater. I
can see it in your eyes.